dylan congratulations on the film the
reviews that i've read have obviously
been amazing and i thought it was
i completely agreed and one called it of
course
sorry
one called it a horror story for the
influencer age would you agree with that
whoa that's an interesting take see this
i mean this is like what we've been so
excited about to see i don't know what
the interpretations of it are i wouldn't
classify it like that but i think
i think it's a cool
i don't know i think that's that's a
cool take on it i i think horror maybe
sometimes
it can it can allude to like negativity
and i don't think it's taking like a
negative stance on the influencer
culture that's all i'll say
so what would be your take on social
media right now and the need for people
so badly to want to become influencers
um
yeah i mean like
i don't know it's it's uh
it's just it's a part of our world
you know
um yeah and also like what i mean i
don't know why not you know if you if
you can if you can carve out that like
niche for yourself you know it can also
like lead to other avenues that you
might want to pursue you know so if you
sort of like can um accumulate a
following and sort of use it to your
advantage in some kind of
professional sense you know uh or or it
gives you like some you know financial
stability it's like uh yeah i don't know
why not it's just because it's sort of
become another job
uh opportunity i guess so i think that's
i don't think it's a total
i don't think it's like i think maybe
it's predominantly like vainly pursued
but maybe not all you know
um and obviously you play colin and he
has quite the uh style
how closely would you say you relate to
your character
uh how could i relate to him yeah
um
you know i guess uh uh you know he likes
to have a good time um
uh
i don't think he's like a a monster of a
person you know
he's not too far away from it but
uh yeah i don't know you know can bro
down and smoke a joint with colin and
probably not be completely
uh you know wanting to end it all
um obviously this film has a message
within it what do you want viewers to
ultimately take away from it
uh yeah i don't know i that's
what i'm so curious to see i think
because like there's
uh it's kind of got this wrapped up
little
hidden token at the center of it that i
don't think anyone's like gonna see
coming
and i think that's like a really
cool piece of
the movie it's really the epicenter of
the film and it's i think not been
revealed at all which is very cool um
and
without staying too much i just think
it's i think it'll be really cool to see
sort of the conversations that come you
know from
from people's take on that i think i
don't think anyone will have
um
you know
any one person will just like the same
take i think it'll be pretty
uh a pretty big variety you know
and what impact do you think it's gonna
have on the next generation of
tick-tockers instagramers
the whole social media realm
not sure
i'd it'd be intere you know if it became
at all part of the fold of like how we
what we evolved to next you know um
uh that'd be interesting but i i don't
know i don't know i think it's sort of
just like runs alongside it you know
it's kind of just uh
there's just a relevance to it because
that's just what
that's just sort of culturally like
where we at it's so embedded in in our
culture you know um
it'll be interesting to see what the
next iteration of it is like you know
how like tick tock's the most recent one
you know and um i still remember just
like i feel like it goes so rapidly i
feel like two years ago i remember still
saying like what's tick-tock you know
and then yeah
uh you know and then it just got it it
happens so quickly
and now that question would just get you
like completely laughed at
it's just wild
you